cette vidéo est sponsorisée par Xiaomi
Xiaomi c'est une marque présente en
France depuis 3 ans et ça n'est pas que
des smartphones Xiaomi c'est tout un
écosystème et maintenant retrouver le
Xiaomi 12 et 12 Pro des téléphones au
design élégant et à la finition haut de
gamme doté d'un écran ultra smooth de
12Hz d'un système de son conçu par Arman
Cardon vous serez transporté par son
processeur 5G surpuissant le Snapdragon
8 Gen 1 et ça charge ultra rapide en
moins de 20 minutes je sais pas
donnez-moi des vrais arguments on peut
aussi téléphoner avec
mais peut-être serez-vous davantage
intéressé par sa triple caméra haute
résolution 50 mgapixel objectif grand
angle ultra grand temps qui vous
permettra de jouer avec la profondeur de
champ de filmer avec un mode nuit
impressionnant et jusqu'à 8k 8k waouh
attendez j'essaie ça tout de suite ah
incroyable on voit tous les détails de
ma peau maintenant le Xiaomi 12 Pro et
son petit frère le Xiaomi 12 plus
compact c'est aussi toutes les applis
Google Google Map Google Translate
Google assistant et Google Lens qui vous
permet d'identifier des animaux des
objets des plantes des lieux ou même des
monuments c'est une plante c'est une
plante c'est un objet waouh c'est
incroyable comment j'ai pu me passer de
ça avant utilisez le lien dans la
description pour profiter du Xiaomi 12 à
partir de 899 € et du 12 Pro pour 1099
€.
Xiaomi et maintenant retrouvons une
nouvelle histoire de papy grenier papy
coucou papi papi grenier oh les enfants
vous venez profiter de votre papi avant
qu'il soit plus là hein c'est ça papi
non oui parce que la semaine prochaine
on me change de chambre alors je serai
plus là papi papi tu nous racontes une
histoire non une histoire est-ce que je
vous ai raconter l'histoire de ce vieil
indien qui est à côté de vous depuis le
début qui a jamais rien dit oui je sais
oui ça surprend mais il est gentil vous
inquiétez pas commissaire Navaro alors
ça sert à rien de se disputer oui c'est
un Navaro et je crois
fait pe importe est-ce que je vous ai
plutôt raconté la fois où j'étais
assassin c'était en l'an 2000 j'étais le
47e clone d'une agence secrète
internationale doté de 47 chromonosomes
et on m'appelait Roger j'étais connu
sous le nom de Hitman un tueur à gage
j'avais des gants d'assassin un costume
extrêmement cher et plus du tout
d'argent pour le maquillage je
travaillais pour une agence super
secrète qui s'appelait l'agence l'agence
de quoi papi benah rien l'agence c'est
tout et on se battait aussi contre une
organisation gouvernementale appelé la
franchise papi je crois qu'il manque des
mots la ferme au je mon nom de code
c'était 47 j'avais été cloné à base de C
paires différents tous d'excellents
agents secrets papi pourquoi le 4 tu pas
le sujet ta gueule mon métier c'était
d'assassiner les gens c'est pour ça que
je devais avoir la la plus neutre et un
costume passe partout pour ne pas
attirer l'attention quand je faisais mes
cles j'avais unur très compréhensif il
était toujours très fier de
moi toujours j'étais spécial beaucoup
Dey dans la formation de agents
entier pour s'entraîner en toute
sécurité mais papi tu l'as tué pour de
vrai non c'était des balles en caoutchou
mais non tu l'as étranglé non mais
c'était une nuque en caoutchou j'avais
un paquet de gadget à ma disposition
comme par exemple une corde à piano et
une pièce de 5 francs et et ben c'est
tout d'sf qui assassine les
petites entreprise mais l'essentiel
c'était de savoir s'adapter aux
situations sur place par exemple ce
meffin pour vous c'est simplement un
délicieux gâteau chocolaté truffé de
petitte pépites au cacao mais pour moi
c'est une arme blanche chocolaté trufé
de petite pépite au cacao cible
localisée monsieur pourriez-vous partir
s'il vous plaît d'accord mes missions on
commencé toujours de la même façon un
lieu une cible un
briefing bonjour 47 bienvenue à
tourquois
votre cible s'appelle Chloé cot elle est
la responsable d'une organisation
terroriste néonazi communiste qui agit
sur l'ensemble de la planète et plus
particulièrement dans la Creuse
elle a enrôé des milliers de fidèles
emregadés à sa cause votre mission est
simple 47 infiltrez-vous dans le repère
de cette secte et éliminez la cible
soyez prud ils F dangereux ilait la
jouer F pour réussir à assin ennemis
parfois on risquait de se faire fouiller
alors il fallait jeter ses armes pour
pouvoir passer les contrôles et n'avoir
rien de louche sur
soi un pied de biche une bouteille de
propane une batterie de voiture un faer
passer du 18e non bah c'est bon vous
pouvez y aller monsieur
habibembala les dégisement c'était
crucial c'était la moitié de mon travail
observer la foule sélectionner une cible
et surtout chercher celle qui me
permettrait d'accéder à des endroits
inaccessibles
avant je suis à la peine pack
enfin ensuite l'important c'était de
prendre son apparence jusqu'au moindre
détail pour rentrer dans la peau d'une
autre personne l'illusion devait être
parfaite si on voulait réussir à
approcher de sa cible sans être repéré
messieur je vous présente monsieur
Itachi sabato pdgcoup pharmaceutique
sabato monsieur Itachi laissez-moi vous
présenter vos collaborateurs monsieur
lchi chef de la
sécurité monsieur Kazuki département
scientifique monsieur Kaka votre
cuisiner personnelle
bonjour après il fallait faire attention
bien sûr la plupart des gens se
laissaient avoir par mon talent mais
certains étaient plus vigilants que
d'autres il y a un mec chelou
là-bas il fallait juste les esquiver de
manière discrète et surtout ne jamais
agir bizarrement face à
eux je reconnais pas ce mec mais vu
qu'il regarde au sol il m'a l'air
clairement innocent il y avait plusieurs
techniques d'assassin pour éviter
d'attirer les soupçons on pouvait par
exemple se dissimuler au milieu de la
foule ce mec aussi effuer une activité
discrète pour passer inaperçu on cherche
un Chau déguisé en barman avec un ce sur
le
cou non c'est pas lui lui croise les
bras oh mon
die non c'est pas lui maises papis ils
sont pas débiles les méchants oui c'est
vrai que heureusement on n'ffrontait pas
souvent des génies hein monsieur toutes
ces photos on étaient prises par la même
caméra de
sécurité il doit y avoir un lien entre
toutes ces morts mais
[Musique]
lequel tu pensais pouvoir me baiser mais
je suis plus malin que toi avec qui tu
bosses
mon client n'a plus rien à vous dire s
infiltré pour réussir à approcher la
cible c'était toute une paire de marches
les garde bon ça changeit tout le temps
des fois c'était des gens ultra
nerveux non mais vous avez quand même
tué quatre enfants là oui mais ils
étaient dans la salle de l'aspirateur
ils ont pas le droit d'être dans la
salle de l'aspirateur alors comme ça
maintenant tout le monde il peut aller
dans la salle de l'aspirateur hein moi
je vais mettre un aspirateur dans la
salle des enfants tiens non mais les
écoute pas les écoute pas va bien se
passé et des fois c'était des énormes
[Musique]
branleurs excusez-moi vous auriez vu mon
ami Jérémy il fait 1,65 porte les mêmes
vêtements que vous sauf que lui ça lui
va bien heureusement pour moi je pouvais
planquer les corps dans des endroits
discretsin et personne ne repéit jamais
les corps que tu cacher papi si des fois
mais bon les gens allaient pas s'arrêter
de vivre pour si peu hein alors on vient
de m'informer qu'on vient de retrouver
trois cadavres dans les
vestière mais ne vous inquiétez pas il
ne s'agit que de simple
manutentionnaire mais heureusement la
plupart du temps j'étais discret j'avais
tout un panel de technique pour
distraire les gardes sans viol
et la plus connue c'était la technique
de la
pièce
oh une
oh une deuxième
pièce oh mais c'est littéralement
Noël regarde ce que j'ai ramené
aujourd'hui c'est
génial par contre il faut que je change
de taf parce que mon patron a été assass
évidemment le but au fond c'était
d'atteindre ma cible et étrangement
elles avaient toujours tendance à se
mettre dans des situations dangereuses
et maintenant mesam messieurs J'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Chloé
[Applaudissements]
coton bonsoir merci à tous je suis très
heureuse de vous retrouver sous cet
énorme lustre la seconde étape ensuite
c'était de comprendre les mouvement de
ma cible heureusement c'était plutôt
simple j' avais toute
une une certaine routine quoi merci à
tous je reviendrai refaire le même
discours dans 10 minutes environ après
avoir inspecté la falaise mortelle
j'espère que tout le monde a bien noté
ses places trè étape la suivre
discrètement comme son omombre il y en
avait vraiment pas deux pour suivre les
gens de près comme moi j'étais tel la
discrète brise dev vent posé sur la joue
de mes cibles une nombre furtive qui se
dissimule à votre regard comme un
souffle sans nom et Papi suivre
quelqu'un comme son nombre ça veut pas
dire littéralement comme son nombre ou
j'avais plusieurs techniques pour tuer
mes cibles donc quelquesunes qui étaient
mes
favorites je reviens j'en ai pas pour
[Musique]
longtemps bonjour bonjour
malheureusement je pouvais pas faire ça
là ce jourl elle était constipée mais
heureusement c'était pas les occasions
qui
manquaient j'adore boire de l'eau bien
fraîche mais c'est aussi important de
bien manger
après un bon repas je fais toujours une
petite sieste à l'ombre d'un rouleau
compresseur je pense que j'avais trouvé
la manière discrète et parfaite pour
tuer ma cible merci merci à vous tous
pour vos donation merci
[Musique]
c'est pas une histoire ça c'est un jeu
vidéo comment ça un jeu vidéo et comment
vous expliquer que chis Chau hein ben ça
c'est la chimio papi ah ben oui c'est
vrai j'avais oublié à cause
d'Alzheimer bonjour les enfants papi
papi tu nous racontes une autre histoire
non bien sûr mais ça sera pour la
prochaine fois
[Musique]